late last Friday the Texas Board of
Education voted to remove mention of
powerful women from their history
curriculum Hillary Clinton and Helen
Keller specifically those are the two
that the Texas Board of Education said
you know what we're not going to teach
anything about Hillary Clinton or Helen
Keller anymore as uh there's just not
enough time in the day to get through
all those things so Hillary Clinton and
Helen Keller you are out of Texas
schools effective very soon here's the
thing I don't care if you like Hillary
Clinton if you love Hillary Clinton or
if you hate Hillary Clinton the woman
has made an impact on history and that
is undeniable much the same way as
Donald Trump personally I can't stand
the man but you can't deny that he
hasn't had an impact on this country
Hillary Clinton's same way she was a
first lady for eight years than a u.s.
senator than a Secretary of State and
then the first female nominee of a major
party here in the United States that is
historic and children the 5.4 million
children going to school in the state of
Texas deserve to learn about that
wouldn't you think Helen Keller you know
a story that everybody in this country
learns about because it is such an
inspiring story this woman who nobody
thought would ever even be able to
function making these great strides and
this progress is a great story that if
you concentrate if you put your mind to
it if you put forth the effort and
there's no adversity too great that you
can't overcome that is what that story
is about and it was a powerful woman
Helen Keller that did it and they want
to take that out of the schools in Texas
they also equally is disgusting want to
take out any mention of optimism when
talking about immigrants so they want to
go back through history you can probably
remember I remember it vividly
pictures in in my middle school history
books of immigrants on boats waving at
the Statue of Liberty as they you know
pull into New York Harbor come in here
for better life they wanted something
better than what they had back home
optimism was the main theme they're
taking that out of schools in Texas they
don't want people to think of immigrants
as human beings who just want something
better
no these are illegal invaders coming in
you can't say that they're happy or that
they want to contribute to society no
that might send the wrong message in the
state of Texas so those are the things
that are taken out so what are they
going to replace them with
judeo-christian teachings and Moses they
want to add into the curriculum
discussions about how Moses and the Ten
Commandments really laid the groundwork
for the founding of the United States
and our own Constitution so they're
taking out real people that we can
verify have existed and instead
replacing them with characters from the
Bible that may or may not have been real
really not a lot of evidence to suggest
that they were I don't mean to offend
anyone's religious beliefs with that but
that shouldn't be allowed in schools in
fact I believe there's a document that
kind of runs our country that says you
can but don't tell that to the folks
down there at the Texas Board of
Education is they're gonna make sure
that they get that in while removing
mentions of Hillary Clinton and Helen
Keller oh and by the way you know how
much time they're gonna save not talking
about Helen Keller each year they've
estimated it to be 40 minutes Hillary
Clinton 30 minutes so they're saving an
hour and 10 minutes per year by cutting
out two powerful women from history we
need to take a quick break but you can
follow me on twitter at aaron balance
you can also find me on youtube at
youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire
I am fairing cousin sitting in for David
Pakman who will return tomorrow we'll be
right back with more today's program
brought to you in part
by Blink asam / Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular nonfiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber
which I listened to on blinka they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a 7 day free trial by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about 5 bucks a month that's be Li NK is
t.com /pa que mas